at this point I'm almost sick of
explaining over and over again the tax
cuts for the rich don't stimulate the
economy and that tax cuts for businesses
don't trigger hiring or help the economy
the CEOs mostly get this as well
remember when White House chief
economist advisor Gary cone was at that
Wall Street Journal event and he said
how many CEOs here are gonna invest more
and hire people if the tax bill passes
and almost nobody raised their hands and
now we have yet another CEO who admits
that yeah even if the tax plan passes
which it has and the corporate tax rate
is reduced from thirty five to twenty
one percent that Wells Fargo in this
case is not going to hire anybody else
this is according to their CEO Tim Sloan
from an interview with CNN who said is
it our goal to increase return to our
shareholders and do we have an excess
amount of capital the answer to both is
yes so our expectations should be that
we will continue to increase our
dividend and our share buybacks next
year and the year after that and the
year after that he's telling us they're
gonna do two things increase the return
to shareholders not employees by
increasing dividends and by buying back
their own stock with the extra money
which is going to further raise the
price of that stock growing income
inequality and the logic is really
simple corporate taxes to a business are
sort of the cost of making profits if
you make a hundred thousand dollars in
profit and the tax rate is 35% you pay
thirty five thousand dollars if the tax
rate is twenty one percent you pay
twenty one thousand dollars investment
in your own business is tax-deductible
meaning you already don't pay taxes on
it so if you have a high tax rate you
avoid thirty five percent in taxes by
investing in the business since it
reduces your profit and it's actually
good for the economy you might hire
people if there was excess demand you
might buy more equipment if there was
excess demand which supports other
businesses if the tax rate is lower you
avoid less taxes by investing in the
business it is a disincentive to invest
in the business
if you can pulp a profits out and pay a
lower tax rate and aside from the math
of it businesses hire people when
there's demand if so many people want
your products that you can't keep up
with demand you hire more staff to make
your product what causes people to
demand your product well one requirement
is they've got to have the money for it
right and cutting the tax rate on
corporations doesn't give people more
money for your product it gives
shareholders money and it gives rich
people money who already can afford your
product the idea that corporate tax cuts
stimulate the economy is laughable to
any thinking individual and there's a
pretty good case to be made that
corporate tax cuts when the effective
tax rate is so low as it is in the
United States can actually be bad for
the economy and the CEOs are admitting
it economists know it trickle-down
economics doesn't work but good luck
explaining it to Trump he doesn't know
what trickle-down is to begin with and
bad CEO honestly I mean he has a
fiduciary responsibility to deliver a
profit to his shareholders right so
maybe he should just lie to parents well
no he said he's admitting that he's
gonna finish shareholders he's actually
saying no you know what this is going to
be used for is just growing the profit
delivered to shareholders we're not
going to do what it is that Trump and
Republicans are claiming we're going to
do and it's interesting that he's
actually being honest partially it's
it's because he doesn't want to make
hiring promises that then he might not
actually be able to follow through that
was nobody won yeah and in addition to
that he doesn't want to be pointed to as
one of the reasons that the tax bill
passed if it ends up not being so good
for the company because they end up
having fewer customers who can afford
their product or service absolute
disaster and I'm glad that at least it's
kind of getting out there and becoming a
discussion because it's too easy just to
repeat that talking point lower
corporate taxes are good for the economy
explain to me how and that's actually
something I plan to talk with Dilbert
creator Scott Adams about in the
interview which we'll start part one
right after this break today's program
is made possible in part by gameful
which is sort of like Netflix for video
games they've got over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can also stream games you don't
even need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s